we caused a paradox and that paradox is
swallowing things
how long do we have four maybe five days
before the rest of existence is blitzed
what was it like working with elliot to
put together this story of victor coming
out it was amazing i mean elliot is one
of my closest friends and i adore him so
deeply and i was very much a part of his
journey
through his transition and still am yes
in what some critics are calling the
most emotional season yet the umbrella
academy will see elliott page's
character transition to victor and the
cast couldn't be more proud
your team is good
i don't think you're better than me a
character and an individual have never
transitioned at the same time on screen
and often i just think it's so special
and i just feel so lucky and so grateful
it didn't need to be this huge thing
that dictated the rest of the season and
it sort of mirrored when ellie had
shared with us don't want to
misrepresent that i think if it was done
wrong we were all had something to say
about it but i mean obviously you know
elliot was leading leading that charge
but yeah yes it was very important for
steve blackman as the writer and creator
of the show that they've got to get it
right i finished the scripts already
when i talked to elliot so i had to go
back and re-graph the stories i had a
lot of help in glad
um who were very good to me and then i
also worked with a a trans writer who
was very helpful i mean i wanted to be
authentic i wanted to be sensitive
spoiler alert